hi I'm Matthew Langford I'm 14 years old
and I study physics at Southern Grammar
School do you believe that there are the
planets in the universe which are
capable of supporting life so Matthew
wants to know do I believe that there
are other planets in the world capable
of supporting life I imagine so there
are about a 100 billion stars in our own
galaxy and there are about a hundred
billion galaxies that we could see and
it seems that about 10% of the stars
that have that look like the Sun do have
planets so it seems pretty likely that
there are planets out there that could
support life now is there life we don't
know yet but we could in the future
because there are ways to find out the
signs of life if we would find oxygen in
the atmosphere of a planet around
another star we would say it must be
alive because oxygen is so reactive that
it cannot exist according to our
thoughts in the atmosphere of a planet
unless something is producing that
oxygen currently so yes we're looking
for oxygen in the in planetary
atmospheres around other stars and when
we find it we would say aha those
planets are alive